und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne Gellinek
Abend das Heizungs hin und her ist noch
nicht zu Ende zwar hat die Regierung die
Austauschpflicht von Öl und Gasheizungen
mit allerhand Ausnahmeregeln und
Übergangsfristen abgeschwächt aber viele
Fragen sind noch offen zum Beispiel die
nicht ganz unerhebliche wer wie viel
Fördergeld für eine klimafreundliche
neue Heizung bekommt und so hagelt es
weiter Kritik aus der Opposition von
Klimaschutz mit der Brechstange und
verarmungsprogramm ist die Rede die
ampelparteien hingegen feiern ihre neu
gewonnene Harmonie Karl Hinterleitner
berichtet aus Berlin
ein Durchbruch sei es gewesen nach
tagelangen Sitzungen gestern Abend
endlich die Einigung der Koalition beim
Thema Heizen und alle sagen sie haben
gewonnen besonders die schwierigen
Partner FDP und Grüne zeigen sich
wechselseitig zufrieden es ist sehr gut
dass wir die Einigung die im
Koalitionsausschuss getroffen haben
jetzt innerhalb von wenigen Tagen
Umsätzen das heißt die ganze Regierung
stellt sich hinter das Vorhaben von
Robert Habeck und Lara Gallwitz das hat
2024 keine neuen Öl und Gasheizung mehr
eingebaut werden sollen sind wir hier
auf klimafreundliche und auf bezahlbare
Alternativen setzen wir haben genau das
erreicht was wir ja die ganze Zeit
angekündigt haben nämlich das weiterhin
ganz viele unterschiedliche Arten von
Heizung möglich sind die Leute nicht
überfordert sind aber natürlich müssen
wir bei der wärmewende vorwärts kommen
und das gibt dieser Gesetzentwurf jetzt
her der Entwurf im Wesentlichen neu
eingebaute Heizungen sondern ab dem
ersten Januar 2024 zu 65% mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
das kann aber muss keine Wärmepumpe sein
auch andere umweltfre mit
sicherheitsarten sind möglich außerdem
gibt es Übergangsfristen 1 allerdings
wurde gestern nicht geklärt die
Bezahlbarkeit wer wie viele Zuschüsse
bekommt bleibt offen dass sei
unausgegoren und zu kurz gegriffen meint
die Opposition in seltener Einigkeit das
wird gesagt dass irgendwie sozial
abgefedert werden muss aber es wird
nicht gesagt wie aber was natürlich
notwendig ist sind direkte Zuschüsse
Förderprogramme die Menschen dürfen
damit nicht allein gelassen werden das
darf nicht die Mieterinnen und Mieter am
Ende auf die umgelegt werden und dann
brauchen wir eine besondere Förderung
besondere Zuschüsse für Menschen mit
geringem Einkommen die Schwierigkeiten
einfach haben so eine Investition zu
schultern da geht's ja um Tausende von
Euro da braucht es besondere
Unterstützung und da kennen wir große
Worte oder Schulz im Bundestag keiner
wird im Stich gelassen aber wir können
kein Konzept
das komme dann noch meinte Olaf Scholz
gestern Abend in Frankfurt versprach der
Kanzler den sozialen Ausgleich habe man
sehr wohl im Blick
haben auch schon diskutiert wie die
soziale Abfederung oder die
Unterstützung von Investitionen von
Bürgern und Bürgern in ihre
Heizungsanlagen vorangehen kann da haben
wir jetzt verschiedene Punkte
zusammengetragen und werden versuchen im
Laufe der nächsten oder übernächsten
Woche auch ein ganz konkretes
Förderkonzept das passt zu dem jetzt
gefunden im gesetzgebungsentwurf
entwickeln das heißt aber auch noch ist
nicht klar was die wärmewende am Ende
kostet der Durchbruch mag gestern
gelungen sein die Rechnung kommt später
der britische Geheimdienst sieht
Russlands Winteroffensive in der
Ostukraine als gescheitert an der Plan
des russischen Generalstabschefs
grassimov die militärische Kontrolle
über die möglichst gesamte
donbass-region zu erlangen werde wohl
nicht aufgehen so die Briten gekämpft
und gestorben wird trotzdem dabei
kontrollieren beide Seiten die Bilder
von der Front die an die Öffentlichkeit
gelangen der ukrainischen Sanitäterin
julia pajewska ist es gelungen Bilder
einer Kamera die sie während ihres
Einsatzes am Körper trug
herauszuschmuggeln aufgenommen während
des Kampfes um Mariupol vor einem Jahr
zeigen sie die Erbarmungslosigkeit
dieses Krieges torgebode hat Julia
pajewska in Düsseldorf getroffen
vor dem Bild von Julia pajewska werden
an diesem Abend jede Menge selfies und
Fotos gemacht
dann kommt sie selbst Julia eine
ukrainische kriegsheldin das riesige
Porträt lässt sie einfach links liegen
die Menschen auf die sie warten aber
nicht die Ukrainerinnen die heute Abend
hier in Düsseldorf sind verehren Julia
danke für alles was du getan hast Julia
pajewska rührt zu etwas der ganze Trubel
um ihre Person ist ihr aber eher
unangenehm
ich bin doch nur eine von vielen die das
erlebt und durchgemacht haben die den
Krieg gesehen haben ich versuche das
nicht auf meine Person allein zu
beziehen auf keinen Fall geht es hier
nur mich
die Soldaten julia kampfnameira ist von
Kriegsbeginn an mittendrin als
Rettungssanitäterin in Mario Polen ihre
Einsätze im Februar und März 2022 Film
sie mit einer bodycam
es waren unfassbar hohe Verluste
unfassbar viele Tote vor allem unter der
Zivilbevölkerung so etwas hatte ich
vorher noch nie gesehen
julia ist schon seit 2014 im Don Bass im
Einsatz aber was sie in mariopol erlebt
bringt sie an ihre Grenzen die Kamera
läuft während ein sechsjähriger Junge
unter ihren Händen stirbt
[Musik]
so etwas zu erleben tut schon sehr weh
auch verletzte russische Soldaten
behandelt sie dann wenige Tage nachdem
diese Aufnahmen gemacht werden wird sie
an einem Checkpoint von russischen
Streitkräften gefangen genommen drei
Monate ist sie Kriegsgefangene sie
berichtet von Folter an Körper und Seele
es war fürchterlich ich konnte mir nicht
vorstellen dass solche Methoden die man
vielleicht aus dem Mittelalter kennt im
21 Jahrhundert noch anwendet
was genau ihr angetan wird und die
Umstände ihrer Freilassung darüber will
Julia nicht sprechen der Fall wird noch
untersucht als Sanitäterin arbeitet
Julia nicht mehr sie ist jetzt eine
Botschafterin ein Gesicht des Krieges
das die Regierung in Kiew gerne vorzeigt
Auftritte in Washington vor dem Kongress
oder eben Vorträge in Deutschland
mich interessiert einzig und allein der
Sieg der Ukraine zum ersten zweiten und
zum dritten Mal nur das ist mir wichtig
wenn ich also meine Heimat helfen kann
indem ich repräsentiere dann tue ich
eben das
Blumen
Autogramme noch mehr Fotos die
Anerkennung die Wertschätzung das alles
hilft dir sagt Julia die eigenen Wunden
zu heilen sie selbst träumt davon in
Ihrem Garten Rosen zu züchten wenn der
Krieg endlich zu Ende ist
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat auch
Auswirkungen auf die Vereinten Nationen
in New York und damit beginnen die
Nachrichten von dir Hanna russland hat
heute Turnus gemäß den Vorsitz des
UN-Sicherheitsrats übernommen was von
deutlicher internationaler Kritik
begleitet wurde unter anderem aus der
Ukraine Präsident selensky forderte am
Abend eine Reform des Gremiums und
bezeichnete Russland als Terrorstaat der
den Frieden zerstöre während der Sitzung
des Sicherheitsrats gab es außerdem
Streit über die Pläne Moskau in Belarus
taktische Atomwaffen zu stationieren
die ausrüstungslücken bei der Bundeswehr
können laut Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius bis 2030 nicht vollends
geschlossen werden das erklärte der
Minister gegenüber der Welt am Sonntag
als Gründe nannte er
Produktionskapazitäten Lieferzeiten und
die Finanzlage historius sagte zudem
dass er den werthar bis zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode erhöhen möchte um das
2% Ziel der NATO zu erreichen
in den USA haben mehrere Tornados
schwere Schäden angerichtet dabei kamen
mindestens 18 Menschen ums Leben
betroffen ist vor allem der mittlere
Westen und Süden der Vereinigten Staaten
in einem Theater in
Illinois stürzte während eines Konzerts
das Dach ein dabei starb mindestens ein
Mensch etwa 30 Personen wurden verletzt
drei Tage lang war Papst franziskus
wegen einer Bronchitis im Krankenhaus in
Behandlung nun ist das Oberhaupt der
katholischen Kirche wieder entlassen
worden der Vatikan kündigte an das
franziskus wie geplant an allen
Gottesdiensten der Karwoche und der
Ostertage teilnehmen werde
zum Sport und damit zum Topspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga heute Bayern gegen
Dortmund bei dem die Bayern und ihr
neuer Trainer Thomas Tuchel triumphieren
konnten am Ende stand es vier zu zwei
und der Rekordmeister ist wieder
Tabellenführer mehr dazu gleich im
Aktuellen Sportstudio
und jetzt haben wir noch was zu feiern
in eigener Sache denn genau heute Abend
vor 60 Jahren begann das ZDF für sie zu
senden los ging es natürlich nicht aus
einem digitalen
hightech-nachrichtenstudio wie diesem
sondern bodenständig und sehr
provisorisch auf dem Gelände eines
ehemaligen Bauernhofs in der Nähe von
Frankfurt am Main zum Teil baufällig
stand auf einem Schild vorm Studio wir
lassen die alten Zeiten noch mal
aufleben aus dem allerersten
heute-studio damals wurde dort übrigens
noch geraucht darin standen solche
Originalen röhrenkameras von denen wir
noch eine ausgegraben haben der
Moderator saß an einem Tisch auf einem
Podest das heute journal war noch nicht
erfunden doch schon damals gab es einen
Moderator für die Kurznachrichten und
einen hauptmoderator
1963 waren das natürlich alles Männer
der Vorspann oder das Opening wie wir
heute sagen würden klang so
heute in den frühen 60ern waren die
schnellsten Verbindungen nach draußen
Fernschreiber und ein simples Telefon
zum Schalten in die große weite Welt die
erste Frau im Studio gab es übrigens
erst 8 Jahre später mit Wiebke Bruns
immerhin die erste
Nachrichtenmoderatorin im westdeutschen
Fernsehen
Christel Haas schaut jetzt zurück wie es
mit dem zweiten deutschen Fernsehen
damals losging und sie beginnt mit den
treuesten zdf-kollegen die wir haben
um es gleich vorwegzunehmen die
unumstrittenen dauerlieblinge sind diese
fröhlichen ZDF Mitarbeiter seit 60
Jahren fast unverändert
man brauchte schon gutes Schuhwerk und
Pioniergeist damals als alles anfing im
Matsch im sogenannten telezibirsk alles
war improvisiert und doch hat's
funktioniert
guten Abend meine Damen und Herren in
diesem Fall österlichen Tagen
interessiert die Hausfrau besonders der
eierpreis rund 50 Millionen Hennen
stehen in der Bundesrepublik für die
Eierproduktion zur Verfügung guten Abend
auch wenn die Köpfe und die Deko sich
veränderten
15 Jahre später taucht ein Neuling auf
mit ganz eigenem nachrichtenanspruch
da gibt es den Spruch die anderen melden
alle Minister hat Handtuch geworfen und
das heute journal sagt wohin das ist
nicht immer einfach trotz hartnäckigem
nachfragen
bei anderen Parteien Frau lassen Sie uns
den Quatsch beenden
was ich gesagt habe und wer sagt
eigentlich das Nachrichten immer ernst
sein müssen unser liebes altes Mainz ist
dankbariontech plötzlich das reichste
provinzkraft der Welt wir dachten die
furchtbare Zeit vorbei aber dann kam der
mistweg voller Boden wir können das
läuft wieder jedes Jahr
Wetten je verrückter desto besser Kult
familienshows zum Mitraten
[Applaus]
die Mutter aller Arztserien begann hier
Herz und Gefühl in der Klinik
[Musik]
morgen mein Name ist Brinkmann ich bin
der neue Chefarzt und natürlich mit dem
schönen Udo Herzensbrecher und
Sportskanone
womit wir schon bei diesem zdf-highlight
wären das aktuelle sportstudio und seine
legendäre Torwand
[Musik]
ich finde der 60 Geburtstag ist einer
der schönsten Geburtstag weil man viel
Lebenserfahrung hat und trotzdem weit
nach vorne gucken kann von daher nein
wir sind nicht in die Jahre gekommen und
ja wir schauen weiter nach vorne na dann
auf die nächsten 60
und ich habe den Eindruck gehabt heute
schon genug geguckt in die Glotze nehmen
also abschalten
und wenn sie sich selbst im ersten heute
Studium mal umschauen wollen empfehlen
wir Ihnen unsere interaktive 3D Story
auf heute.de und in unserer App mit
vielen Fotos und Ausschnitten von damals
und jetzt die Lottozahlen von diesem
Samstag die lauten 27 28 33 36 42 45
Superzahl 9 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
es gibt aktuell eine Unwetterwarnung des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes und zwar vor
ergiebigem Dauerregen in Teilen von
Nordrhein-Westfalen Hessen
Baden-Württemberg und Rheinland-Pfalz
infolgedessen kann es unter anderem zu
Hochwasser an Bächen und kleineren
Flüssen kommen und so wird das Wetter in
den kommenden Tagen morgen im Norden
trocken und häufig Sonne im Süden
regnerisch es wird ein frischer
nord-ostwind bei vier bis zwölf Grad ab
Montag dann meist ein trockener Sonne
wolken-mix mit nur wenigen Schnee oder
Regenschauern bei einem lebhaften
Nordostwind werden drei bis zwölf Grad
erreicht
das war es von uns an diesem
geburtstagssamstag des ZDF und hier
geht's gleich weiter mit dem Aktuellen
Sportstudio
und die nächsten Nachrichten gibt es
dann gegen 0:30 Uhr heute Express mit
Antoine und uns beiden gibt es morgen
wieder einen schönen Abend tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]